while Russia's defense Ministry has
accused Ukraine of what it caused a
terrorist attack after a drone strike on
Moscow a presidential Aid denied that
Kiev was directly involved though
moscow's mayor said several buildings
were hit Sergey sabyan said the attack
caused minor damage but no one was
seriously injured Russia says it
intercepted eight drones
[Music]
and that comes as Ukraine says it shot
down more than 20 Russian drones Q says
at least one person was killed in those
latest airstrikes the city's mayor
called it a massive attack Moscow has
intensified strikes on the capital the
attack was the third on the capital in
24 hours well let's now speak to
journalist Julia chapovalova in Moscow
Yulia we've been seeing these cordons
set up and police on the streets there
what more do we know at this stage
okay
so basically it's been the most massive
attack on Moscow and the Moscow region
since the beginning of the so-called
special military operation in Ukraine
and now we've received official
information from Russia's Ministry of
Defense they called the UAV attacks and
acts of Terror committed by the Kiev
regime eight aircraft type unmanned Aero
Vehicles were involved in that tag and
all of the enemy drones were destroyed
by Air Defense Forces that's according
to the ministry of Defense so we
understand that the drones attacked the
Western and South western parts of
Moscow and the Moscow Region Three uavs
crashed into residential buildings one
of the drones had been carrying
explosive devices that actually did not
detonate according to Moscow mayor
sabyani and so people asked for medical
help after the fall of one of the uavs
in Moscow police emergency services and
several ambulance
teams continue to work at the crash
sites in Moscow and the residents of one
of the blocks of flats in the
southwestern part of Moscow have been
evacuated and the territory around their
apartment block has been cordoned off
and there are also reports that another
woman has been injured in the Moscow
region while authorities say that
basically this city functioning as usual
Julia you say this is the largest attack
yet on the capital how are people in
Moscow reacting
well it's interesting because people on
the streets are very calm and many are
going to work some are running around
the city are doing their chores and all
public transport including the Metro uh
functioning as always and all airports
in Moscow and the region are working as
usual no flights have been canceled as
we know we have also heard from the head
of the Wagner Group by the way uh from
Mr pregosian he said that the ministry
of Defense allows drones to fly into
areas of Moscow and the Moscow region
where civilians live and
basically he condemned the ministry of
Defense blaming them for uh for things
like those and I should tell you that
many people here in Russia
truly believe the information they
regularly hear on TV and they believe
that the conflicts between Russia and
Ukraine brain had been inevitable and
President Putin basically began that
conflict first on foreign soil therefore
Russia is protected and many quote Putin
as saying that if a big fight is
inevitable you have to hit first and
since February 2022 we know that
Russia's a special military operation
has been carried out on Ukrainian soil
and many Russians have been watching the
conflict on TV and right now all of us
are able to watch it from the window
Julius approval over there with the
latest for us from the Russian capital
thank you Yulia
well as I was saying earlier there were
strikes in the Ukrainian Capital too her
correspondent Natasha Butler has been
there speaking to people in Kiev and has
this update for us on the latest Russian
attack there
well people have come down to see what
has happened here they're looking at
their cars that have been really badly
damaged the roofs smashed the windows uh
broken a lot of dust and a lot of debris
here and all of this has happened
because of what uh happened last night
to this building it was uh struck the
top floors nearly in Ruins and Emergency
Services say that a woman was killed a
number of people injured no surprise
when you see the extent of the damage
here people are in Shock you know they
are walking around they can't quite
absorb what has happened even though
this is their worst nightmare uh come
true if you will because every night
when the sirens go during these attacks
by Russia they wonder what will happen
in the night they're going to shelters
their children are scared but they don't
know what the night will bring they
don't know what the next hour will bring